this will ensure that unemployed
Americans of all backgrounds will be
first in line for jobs as our economy
reopens crucially it will also preserve
our health care resources for American
patients we have to take care of our
great American workers and that's what
we're doing so president Trump's
executive order to halt some legal
immigration amid the Cova 19 pandemic
takes effect today the measure which
makes exceptions for a variety of cases
including those seeking temporary visas
is set for 60 days though the president
says he can extend it if the time frame
if need be so here now with the details
on that order acting Secretary of
Homeland Security Chad Wolfe sir good to
see thank you very much for being here
tonight one of the there's criticism of
this on both sides and one of them is
that it's too it has too many exclusions
that it includes people who are already
living and working here those who are
seeking to become legal permanent
residents medical professions
farmworkers those who enter on a
temporary non-immigrant visa also
unaffected also the spouses and
underaged children of US citizens are
unaffected who does that leave that is
actually going to be affected by this
well thank you for having me Martha Ann
I think what we see here is this is a
very targeted approach that the
president president has taken so it
affects new immigrants that are coming
to the US these are individuals that are
competing with Americans for jobs
basically any job in any industry and
that's really what the president is
targeting so it's these are new
immigrants coming to the US as you
indicated there's a number of exceptions
and and really the critical ones are
those individuals coming too that are
participating in the medical field
health care industry medical research
and others devoted to kovat 19 fighting
kovat 19 and so there are certain
restrictions in there for that but again
this is a targeted approach and it's
really really the the importance here is
making sure that we're protecting
American jobs I think what we've seen
here and the president has realized is
we have 26 million Americans that are
filing unemployment claims
and we want to make sure that those
individuals can rejoin the economy
maintain their jobs regain their jobs
regain their livelihood as we come out
of this pandemic and as we kick start
the economy so this is a first step as
you indicated I think you'll see
additional steps in in that executive
order that the President issued
yesterday it actually directs the
Department of Homeland Security as well
as the Department of Labor to look at
these non-immigrant or temporary visa
programs and come back to him with
recommendations and that's something
that the department has been looking at
for the past several months so we're
well underway and and look forward to
presenting to the president those
recommendations for additional steps I
mean there's a lot of reason to think
that the job markets gonna stay very
tight even after things open up because
a lot of employers have sort of cut the
ranks and may decide that they don't
want to add to them initially or maybe
ever in some of these cases so there's
clearly gonna be some tightness in the
labor market the criticism on the other
side is takes takes this form this is
from max boot in the Washington Post the
columnist he writes there's no
justification for stopping the
immigration process all you have to do
is test new arrivals for the coronavirus
by stopping all immigration to a nation
of immigrants Trump is doing
incalculable damage to our public health
economic well-being and national
character but from his perspective that
is a small price to pay for energizing
his nativist base what do you say to
that Chad well it's it's absolutely
incorrect again the president's being
very targeted as I indicated and again
we're looking at new immigrants so as
you indicated earlier we're not looking
and this is not focused on immigrants
that are already here and already
participating we're talking about new
immigrants who will come in and compete
with Americans for again jobs in almost
any industry and any jobs and so what
the president has been singularly
focused on really from the beginning of
the administration is making sure to
protect American people and in this case
protecting American jobs and again this
is the first phase of that the first
approach to that looking at immigrants
coming in and making sure that Americans
have have really the first claim at
those jobs as the economy kicks up and
running there's additional steps that we
can take and the president's been very
open to that and we'll continue to look
at those as we move forward
quick quick last question for you on who
gets to come into the country in terms
of travel we saw the shutdown's China UK
Europe you know it feels like as we get
our sea legs under us with this thing
that some would want to see that
extended to make sure that the country
is not bringing in anything from the
outside is that the plan
what can you tell us it is the plan so a
number of the countries that we have
travel restrictions on there's 30 of
them in total those restrictions stay in
place and just last week we extended the
non-essential travel that agreements
that we have in place with both Mexico
in Canada which have done been very
successful over our land borders again
on northern border and southern border
cutting down almost 70% on that
non-essential travel so in discussions
with my colleagues in both Canada and
Mexico we decided to extend that for
additional 30 days and so I think it's
very important that as we begin to phase
in different states are phasing and
opening back up and we're trying to
restart the economy that we don't reseed
the virus coming back into the u.s. from
overseas so I think it's actually
critical to maintain these travel
restrictions for a little bit longer so
we see how this plays out seems like a
good idea a DHS secretary Chad Wolfe
thank you very much good to see you
tonight
thank you